LAURA LING: Lincoln Park has
achieved tremendous success.
You guys are regarded as one
of the most respected rock
bands in the world.
What do you think got you
guys to where you are today?
MIKE SHINODA: There's
elements of hard work,
and there's elements
of chemistry,
and magic, and luck, I'd
say at the bottom of it
all we have had to have a
foundation built on the music.
We learned very early
on that we never
wanted to put
anything on our record
that we didn't feel
100% confident of.
LISA LING: Tell me about your
solo project, Fort Minor.
MIKE SHINODA: A lot of
people are confused by it
because it has a name.
It's not just Mike Shinoda.
For me, it's a place where
whether it's music or art,
it's just me.
LISA LING: So would you say
then that music and visual art
are your rituals,
things that you just
have to do and thrive on?
MIKE SHINODA: If I
go for a few days
without doing something
creative, I get weird.
I get crazy.
Whether it's music or drawing,
painting, anything like that,
art for me, it's like
breathing in the sense
that I don't think about.
I just do it.
LISA LING: And what
do you feel when you
have pen or pencil to paper?
MIKE SHINODA: There are
sometimes when I'm painting,
drawing that I'm really
calm, and it's very soothing
to do it.
And there are other times
when I'm hyper agitated.
In my head, its like a cyclone
of noise, and it's loud.
My mind wanders off
to some crazy place
and it just goes into that
dream state or something.
And maybe that's why
it's so addicting for me,
because I never know
what is going to happen.
LISA LING: Can you tell me how
your visual art has influenced
you in this new song
with Fort Minor.
MIKE SHINODA: The song
is an outsider song,
and the words are really
from an underdog perspective.
And in spite of that, the
tone is a very confident tone.
I wanted to do something
with the art that
felt like it related to that,
and so I went down to Venice,
and did this mural on
1,000 record jackets.
And I basically came up with
all these different characters
that I thought of when
I listened to the song.
So I started drawing people,
and this is what I came up with.
LISA LING: And so
are these, would you
say, representations of the
underdogs in our society?
MIKE SHINODA: Yeah, so it
was a gut feeling of this
is who feels like the
song, and feels like what
I'm getting at with this piece.
LISA LING: How
would you describe
the style of your artwork?
MIKE SHINODA: My favorite
things to draw growing up
were basically
Nintendo characters
because I was
obsessed with that,
and then eventually got into
movies, like Akira and Princess
Mononoke.
But all of those
things kind of mesh
together to create
whatever it is that I do.
I don't really know
what to call it.
LISA LING: Shinoda.
MIKE SHINODA: Shinoda.
LISA LING: What do you
hope people get out
of not only your music
but also your visual art?
MIKE SHINODA: When
I'm making something,
sometimes I have a
very specific message
with some of the pieces,
and just like most artists,
coping with your own story and
your own reactions and emotions
and things.
In its best form,
it's like therapy.
And then the other half is
what are people extracting
from whatever you've made?
It's not done until somebody
else sees it and reacts to.
That's the other half
of the experience.
LISA LING: I hope
you enjoyed learning
about Mike Shinoda's creative
process, and his ritual of art.
To see more stories from this
series, please subscribe.
And you can also
watch this episode
about a young man who was
bullied as a child that
emerged stronger than ever.
When you look in the mirror now
who's the person that you see?
YOUNG MAN: So I see a lot
more confident person,
I see someone who's made a lot
of progress, and most of all,
I see someone
who's on a journey.